was going to be that everyone was going
to turn into mike rowe that we were all
going to begin to appreciate the people
who make this country work the people
who keep us safe the people that keep us
healthy in the hospitals um but what we
can see mike is that you know as soon as
it interferes with the political agenda
or some big donors like big pharma they
just
throw those workers you know to the curb
like like garbage which by the way isn't
getting picked up either
no and i think there's more to it than
that you know there's something in us
there's just a it's the fault in our
stars you know where we begin to resent
the very thing we rely upon
and in so many cases you know my my
career has been spent mostly trying to
find the workers who are out of sight
and therefore out of mind and just
tapping the country on the shoulder and
saying hey
what about him what about her check
these guys out tonight on the show
we profile airport workers ironically
and yeah to your point i got here five
minutes ago my flight was delayed two
hours there were no flight attendants
that's a united flight by the way
so this is happening all over the place
and there are a gajillion different ways
to talk about it but when i stay in my
lane
typically what i say is look this whole
problem this disconnect this skills gap
11 million open jobs this isn't a
mystery this is a reflection of what we
value and our country has become
disconnected from the kinds of jobs that
you're talking about right now we're not
properly gobsmacked when we turn on the
switch and the lights come on or when we
flush the toilet and it all goes away so
it's no great mystery why our kids
aren't eager to fill these positions we
take them for granted ourselves but is
it we or is it the people in charge the
elites who don't who don't appreciate it
i know i appreciate the people who come
to pick up my garbage i'm grateful when
i turn the light switch on i spoke to a
truck driver on fox and friends mike and
he said you know it's not just all the
regulations around this but people tell
the government and and and the the woke
social justice culture tells our kids
that you know my job is killing is
killing people it's a it's a you know it
doesn't have that kind you know it's a
fossil fuel you know job so there's all
these factors coming in socially but at
the very end of the day isn't it our
leaders
look i'm not going to defend it i think
they've been ignorant of a lot of
unintended consequences that come along
with a lot of policies in play right now
right but i also believe that a lot of
parents today
will say what you just said but when it
comes to their own kids
they'll step back a little bit right
they're not quite so sure that there's a
six-figure career in welding well guess
what there is
yeah no you make a good point although
trucking is paying a lot these days um
and they are and they are struggling
they they could hire a hundred thousand
people rachel right now you're right 100
000. you're right well i'm looking
forward to your show especially since
it's about airports and airport workers
thank you so much mike
you'll love it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else